hi in this video we'll be talking about
non-competitive inhibition so what comes
in your mind when you hear the term
non-competitive inhibition in a layman's
term it's just not competitive right we
have earlier discussed the competitive
inhibition paradigm where there is a
substrate which is able to bind to the
enzyme but there is an inhibitor which
is also able to bind to the inhibit
enzyme and both compete for the active
site of the enzyme
now if the inhibitor occupies the active
side of the enzyme the reaction won't
proceed and no product would be formed
so this is the competitive paradigm of
inhibition but what we can understand
from a non-competitive inhibition name
that this kind of paradigm is not
followed there so there is no confusion
between that then what is competed
non-competitive innovation in
non-competitive inhibition the inhibitor
does not compete with the substrate for
the active site that means it doesn't
care whether the substrate is bound to
the active site or not it further means
that the inhibitor binds to a region
which is different from the active site
it might be allosteric site as well now
the inhibitor really don't care whether
the substrate is bound or the enzyme is
alone both the cases in either inhibitor
is able to bind to the enzyme be it in
our enzyme substrate complex or beat
enzyme alone and in each case the
reaction does not proceed and the
reaction halls at that particular time
so this is the basic understanding of
non-competitive inhibition where the
inhibitor don't compete with the
substrate now the special point about
non-competitive inhibition and how it is
different from mixed innovation is the
inhibitor has equal affinity for the
enzyme in a lonely state or a enzyme in
a substrate bound State so both the
situation inhibitor has equal affinity
this is very different from a mixed
inhibition
but in order to understand how
non-competitive inhibition is different
from mixed innovation or a special case
of mixed innovation we need to
understand the equation of mixed
innovation let's try to understand it
mathematically first so here is the
equation parent equation showing that M
enzyme plus substrate could form enzyme
substrate complex which would give rise
to product an enzyme alone now there
could be the inhibitor binding in two
regions either to the enzyme alone or to
the enzyme substrate as well and it
would form enzyme substrate inhibitor
complex or enzyme inhibitor complex and
these two reaction has two different
rate constant for which are like Q I and
K I dashed right now we can write the ki
n ki dashed in this format and further
convert it in terms of the concentration
of enzyme substrate inhibitor and enzyme
an inhibitor which we would be using in
the latter part of the derivation now
total enzyme is a combination of only
enzyme which is free enzyme and
inhibitor complex or some there would be
some amount of enzyme substrate complex
as well where the inhibitor has not
bound now there would be also enzyme
substrate and inhibitor complex so there
would be four entity now if you try to
write the expressions for all these four
different entity we would get something
like this now we know this and this
particular expression we have obtained
previously from the rate constants here
now rearranging it into a little bit
understandable form we get a format like
this now we have two alpha here which is
basically corresponding to two different
rate constants so each of the cases
alpha is 1 by 1 plus I by K I now if we
take enzyme substrate as a common we
reach to this particular expression and
multiplying that both side to K 2 we get
V 0 equal to v-max into s divided by
alpha km plus alpha dash into substrate
concentration
provided v-0 equal to k2 s and V M equal
to v-max equal to k2 ET now this is our
equation for the mixed inhibition we
have two factors alpha and alpha dashed
now for non-competitive inhibition I
repeat for non-competitive inhibition
our K I and K AI dashed are equal
because the enzyme has equal affinity
towards a substrate
towards the enzyme substrate complex and
towards the individual enzyme so both
these risk constant should be equal and
alpha should be equal to alpha dashed
right now in that situation if this is
the equation for mixed inhibition it
would be reduced to V naught equal to
v-max into substrate concentration
divided by km plus substrate
concentration into 1 by alpha right
because alpha - equal to alpha now we
can clearly understand that km hasn't
changed but v-max has been reduced to a
v-max by alpha so the in the enzymatic
reaction cannot reach its optimum v-max
optimum reaction velocity right so let's
try to understand this same equation in
terms of a graphical representation but
before that the most important point
that we need to understand that in case
of mixed inhibition these two rate
constants are different ki is not equal
to ki dashed
but in case of non-competitive
inhibition ki equal to ki - because
enzyme because the inhibitor has same
affinity towards the enzyme or the
enzyme substrate complex but in case of
mixed inhibition that's not the case the
inhibitor has different affinities
towards the enzyme or it if it is an
enzyme and substrate complex so that is
an important point to keep in mind now
let us look at how a Michaelis Menten
equation look like in a V versus s plot
we know it's like this right now under
circumstances of non-competitive
inhibition
it the curve would look like this well
clearly you can understand the v-max has
decreased to a degree of fee max by
alpha but the team has not really
changed because the substrate that the
inhibitor has not give a damn whether it
is bound to the substrate or the enzyme
is alone so it has equal affinity
towards the enzyme substrate complex and
in the enzyme so the km is unaltered but
the v-max has definitely reduced to we
make to a factor of alpha and that's why
we can see there is a decrease in v-max
now we can understand that the inhibitor
does not discriminate whether the enzyme
is substrate bound or sub-nought
substrate bound so let us take a look at
the lineweaver-burk plot to understand
the kinetic data better in this
situation so in non-competitive
inhibition the lineweaver-burk plot
looks like this or you can see the
intercept in the y axis is different so
the v-max
or the one by v-max which was the
previous intercept now becomes alpha or
alpha - by V Max so if the v-max has
reduced to a degree of alpha right but
the km the intercept at the negative
x-axis is the same right because one of
my cam is the same point right now from
these two plots we can understand the
how that came came and the v-max are
changing under a circumstance of
non-competitive inhibition now let's
take an example we all know first we
know pyruvate with the help of the
enzyme pyruvate kinase gets converted
into pyruvate and that's the last
substrate level phosphorylation step in
the glycolysis pathway right and in this
particular step ADP gets converted to
ATP mistakenly it is written as ATP but
anyway it's get converted to ATP now
here what happens is the amino acid
alanine works as a non-competitive
inhibitor
of pyruvate kinase and thereby it
regulates the glycolytic flux so we can
understand by non-competitive inhibition
glycolysis can be regulated now that
that is the important physiological
context of a non-competitive inhibition
reaction not only that several drugs
which contains cyanide can block the
complex 4 or cytochrome oxidase which is
super important for the electron
transport chain and this kind of
inhibition is also a non-competitive
inhibition which is super efficient in
terms of because it doesn't give a damn
about whether the substrate is bound or
not bound and it is pretty difficult
right I hope you enjoyed this video if
you liked this video give it a thumbs up
don't forget to Like share and subscribe
thank you